das ist kühn der examiner reporters
bewusst kinderlos kann mich sehr gefreut
wir direkt diskussion und fragen die
vertriebskosten in der kommentare ganz
fehlen wie die persönliche geschichte
geschrieben und ein schülervisum sitzen
bestuhlt karlchen wenn
es spannend findet jetzt lasse und es
zeigt wie viel verschiedene grenzt geht
es um ihr kind aber wieder ins bett so
bekannt wurde sind
psychische krankheiten begeben sich mit
roth kinder ins büro oder weil man zum
beispiel angst vor der geburt hatte ich
werde zu fußball für die kommentare egal
und ich die eine oder andere frau oder
das auch verhalten klar
als es können wir zudem kommentare
geschrieben warum interessiert man sich
dafür ob andere menschen kinder wollen
die menschen aufgrund familie
persönliche erfahrung sie wenig im firma
gladbacher mit dem umfeld kind ich habe
die diskussion mit wo kein event und
traumhaft interessiert was sind gründe
wieso man cries hinweg und als 2000 des
bachelors of classics arbeitnehmer wenn
jetzt liegt der film gesandt wo es gar
nicht könnte nachvollziehen wieso mir
jetzt keine welt dass sie eben die
inputs bekümmert wieso man das könnte
und dass sie vielleicht andere leute
besser verstehen und was macht ein thema
aus erläutert ist der kommentar von
alessia eckhard sie schritt wenn es wahr
ist aber auch ihres negatives gefühl bei
kinderwunsch und findet das von mir
selber komisch aber bitte meinung von
sydney dass sie mich
zur adoption in der leyen sie spricht
mir aus der seele dank für die beta
genauso gründen natürlich nicht nur
legitim aber genau zu gründen finde ich
auch wichtig dass man über das thema red
es geschieht was ich unsicher sind die
bereits inspiration oder es geht wo sich
überlegt ins büro und ganz so die
verschiedenen argumente in einer richtig
ist die fehlende kommentar geschrieben
sie findet dass das so argumentationen
wie zb ein klima als rechtfertigung
wolken erwartet und sie findet dass man
selbst nicht rechtfertige ich bin
natürlich auch der meinung dass man sich
in etwas rechtfertigen weil man keuchend
wenn man muss ich gar nicht
rechtfertigen wenn manche internet aber
ich habe zum beispiel aus gefühl dass es
biete sich
neben rechtfertigung sie ist also auch
in ihrem umfeld wisse die wenigste zeit
wieso sie jetzt kann weil sie es einfach
nicht zum thema macht natürlich kann man
dazu sagen wenn sie denn älter wird mit
drei spitzen gespielt wird sie
wahrscheinlich mehr auf das angesprochen
und ich hoffe auch sein dass sie nicht
weiter gewohnt dass sie dir einfach
sagen warum und wenn sie nicht sagen
warum
als die immer wieder ausbauen morgan and
wurde ist thematik rund um man unterwegs
über das ist jetzt also der quote mal wo
man aus der bi hat damit man im titel
mensch verschieben statt frauen ich habe
mir im vorfeld von der reportage ganz
viele gedanken gemacht und auch
unbedingt weil ein marder die hatte mit
verschiedenen meine gehetzt hat ein auch
mit einigem an die dresche und wenig im
film erwähnt dann habe ich heute auf
gemacht verriet wasserschlag im klima
gewinnt entscheidet und endlich auch bei
uns für mann gemeldet ich habe mich dann
aber für sich entschieden weil ich es
wieder einfach so spannend gefunden weil
sie so jung ist und schon bestimmt die
häufigkeit und habe mich darum jetzt
doch für 1 frau entschieden und im alex
ist es mir ist wie im 3 klar wurde dass
eine eigentlich ursprünglich
kinderwunsch korn und hatte auch sehr
spannend gefunden
das eben jetzt der bezirk richtiges hat
sich auch ganz viel gewünscht dass ich
nur mit älteren mit gerät hat zum
beispiel der abraham schritt um einen
kontrast zu all den jungen menschen zu
schaffen solltet ihr ältere oder alte
menschen die keine kinder wollten
interviewen der branche wieder schiebt
diese doku finde ich zu kurz für diese
frage spannend sind die menschen welche
gezeigt werden aber es fehlen mir
eventuell paare die keine kinder kriegen
wollen
für mich ist wichtig sie menschenleben
und da stehen zauber milch das klappt so
beschäftigt an ich werde mit junge leute
wo sich andere überlegungen gemacht und
ich fand es aber durchaus sehr spannend
auch mit älteren
reportagereihe weil freunden und ganz
andere situation und
viel spezieller wenn wir kein kindheit
wenn
markus kramer teil der reportage
natürlich den punkt wenn man kein abitur
also dir das ist natürlich schön und gut
wenn man sich hinter wünscht aber ich
war trotzdem immer im hinterkopf ja was
ist nachdem kein cabrio und das war auch
sehr interessant die frau nicht mehr
aber in firmen nicht stellt
was mich dazu aber sehr gefreut hat ist
der kommentare aktiva der ude und zwar
schiebt sie ich bin eine über 60-jährige
in zwischen altfeministin und habe mein
leben lang mit kindern jugendlichen und
eltern gearbeitet und ich verstehe das
ja natürlich das argument zu 100 prozent
also war ich trotz meiner jüngere
protagonistin
erreicht und das freut mich sehr dass
der diskursen in erwägung stattgefunden
hat sondern dass auch ältere ist die
diskussion mit brachten den ganzen
harzige kommentare und zwar schiebt die
person liebe victoria das tut mir sehr
leid beim schlussapplaus ich hoffe du
lass dich von dem jetzt mit persönlichen
flüsse und durch in wettswil aus eigener
erfahrung sagen dass das möglich ist es
ist zwar streng aber möglich und schön
grußformel studierte 80 prozent schaffen
die
gespräche mit der usa
aufgeführt sie weil es mir einfach nicht
ich hoffe dass es in der schweiz nur so
setzt sie aber es freut mich natürlich
sie jetzt höre dass es auch anders geht
der
klima kreis kind welle finde ich gerade
meine kollegen als vorgeschoben
ich glaube ich finde das nicht
vorgeschrieben was ich aber meine
recherche ist dass es oft ganz viele
verschiedene gekrönt sind nur zwei
spielen und so kommt man denn zu sieben
entscheid dass man kein kind wird das
ist zum beispiel ab
die saarbahn klima sondern aber weil sie
ist einfach eine vorstellung dass sechs
strahlen und sieht einfach kinderwunsch
der david fischer schreibt ich mag den
ausdruck kinderlos nichts da es sich wie
ein bummel anhört ich bin bewusst kinder
frei und würde mich wieder so
entscheiden für mich und für mein leben
passt ist die zwei begriff sind einmal
wieder auf darf die der vorbereitung zum
empfehlen kinderlos und kinder frei ich
habe mich im film für bewusst kinderlos
entschieden weil das meiner meinung nach
am besten abdeckt kinder freilich führt
wohin hält vielleicht eher negativ
kinderlos ist verlockend
negativ und roma nicht dankt wenn ich
bewusst kinderlos nehmen da wird das
ganze wieder super weil sie auch die
bewusst die entscheidung im titel
mitreden das heißt erst mit dem hyundai
wenn er nur wieder die frage ein
spezialfall kommentare geschäftlich
notruf und wenn wir keine weitere
reportagen oder doch für mein
verbesserten aber nicht nachgekommen